yeah part of what makes that balance so
difficult is the CDC now estimates that
as many as 25% of Americans with
coronavirus may not feel any symptoms at
all but still might be able to pass it
on to others so that will make stopping
the spread even more challenging our dr.
David agus joins us from Los Angeles
with more on this dr. agus good morning
very disconcerting to hear that there
are essentially ghost cases out there
people walking with the illness how do
you combat that if you want to try to
slow the spread
well 20% of people or maybe more never
have symptoms with this virus and
obviously they can be contagious but
almost everybody right before they have
symptoms their virus level is actually
very high and they can be contagious too
so you've got an entire population of
people that can spread it so when a
young person says hey I feel fine and
they go on the beach in Florida that
could spread to people who can then
spread it across the country when they
return to their home after Spring Break
it worries me so what do you do about it
what we do about it is we stay at home
what we do it about is we have uniform
rules across the country how we don't go
out because even if we feel fine we can
spread it and then the other thing we
can talk about is masks you know when
you put a mask on it's not actually to
protect you from somebody else it's so
the droplets in your mouth don't get out
when you stand in front of a mirror and
breathe that fog or droplets you put a
mask in front of you you can block the
droplets and so the whole notion of
wearing masks when you go out which is
now mandatory in the city of Los Angeles
where it's recommended of the city less
ended I should say it's to protect
others and I think it's fantastic it's a
good idea as long as you're not wearing
the n95 mask which would be taking masks
away from the medical workers who need
them one of the variables in watching
this crisis unfold is just who is
affected and why we had a 7 week old
baby in Connecticut died just yesterday
I believe and of course people in their
70s 80s and 90s are affected why does
this virus seem to touch so many people
in so many different ways that's the key
question Tony you hit it last week I had
a 50 year old couple who came in and
they both had the virus several days
later the
the wife was on a ventilator the husband
who was in much worse shape than the
wife was fine and actually got better
about 2% of people will have serious
symptoms with this virus and the problem
is I can't protect which 2% so everybody
is worried they're gonna be in that 2%
and if we knew who was in the 2% we can
treat them differently much more
aggressively with medicines and maybe we
figure out why we'll have a clue and how
to stop this horrible disease yeah it's
very interesting you mentioned that the
the husband and wife the the man had
more severe symptoms than the the woman
there's some anecdotal evidence that
that may be the case across the country
any going theories as to why men may be
more affected than women with his FAR's
we first started to see it in China and
we thought it was smoking is that men in
China smoke a lot more use a lot more
tobacco than women we're seeing that
here in the United States we're seeing
another troubling trend in the United
States and that are a population who are
getting symptomatic really symptomatic
or much younger but we're much larger as
a country as an individual and we also
use a lot more blood pressure medicines
we have a lot more blood pressure so
we're not sure the exact reasons for all
of these but these are important
observations that when we figure out the
biology hopefully we'll be able to get a
treatment based on that all right dr.
David agus thank you very much